previously on Johnny Cage goes back to
the future the bad guys took a dirt nap
lots of bad guys it all started when
cronic of got her panties twisted over
Raiden Dustin shinnok and decided to
reboot time the arc of universe ends to
my will of course we weren't gonna let
that happen I mean not when Old Baldy
picks Shao Khan and his goons to be on
her side a new era with them in charge
talk about a total cluster [ __ ] now all
i cronic is mash up a past and present
had us by the balls looked like we were
gonna say good night Gracie
a new era but luckily our merry band
combat kingpins
including yours truly you had a kick ass
take names and not run out of bubblegum
Insecta babe lost some limbs Kano got to
tapped and Garris now sleeps with the
fishes
tell you what though Raiden giving is
God powers to leave Kang's so we could
take down or timeliness
that left my mind
[Music]
still don't understand what old thunder
had mistaken I have merely rated now
I mean sure Luke King finished Chrome
but if we're handing out God powers to
people how am I not better choice
younger you I solemnly swear to tap that
the earliest opportunity
now whatever when it comes down to it
all's well that ends well or so mu King
Fahd there he was at the dawn of time
having a little rap party with Raiden
when who should operate in but the
Godfather of Soul himself Shang soon
tells Liu Kang that he can't rewrite
history without cronic his crown now the
only way to get it is to send him back
to the past are we really gonna trust
our future to that soul sucker sure why
not what's the worst that could happen
things worked out it will make for one
hell of a summer blockbuster I can see
it now Johnny Cage is Johnny Cage and
aftermath whoa they're 90s dad